MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome back
to A20 special relativity.
In this section, I am going to
talk about the deuteron, which
is one of the two stable
isotopes of hydrogen.
The atom is called deuterium.
The nucleus actually contains
one proton and one neutron.
So it's quite simple.
And so we can use this as
an example to understand
the concept of
binding energy and how
we can create objects of heavier
mass or nuclei of heavier mass.
We can do this by bringing
protons and neutrons together.
And when we do that, they
have a likelihood of binding
together to deuterium.
And they release an energy in
form of a photon of 2.3 mev
So the way to understand
is that the combination,
the bound combination of
the protons and neutrons
have more favorable
energy state, which
is visible in this
nuclear potential here.
So the deuteron lives as a
combination of the proton
and the neutron here.
In order to now split up the
deuteron, which is stable,
we have to add energy.
We have to add at
least 2.3 mev of energy
in order to release the
proton and the neutron
and make them free.
The natural abundance of
deuterium in the Earth
is rather limited with
0.0115% in the Earth.
But, nevertheless, deuterium is
extremely useful and extremely
important in the
evolution of the universe,
in the synthesis of
more heavier elements,
as it's kind of a part
of the chain, which
allows the creation of helium.
And then helium can
be used in order
to create even heavier nuclei.
To give you a sense
in the numbers,
the mass of the neutron is
2.01355 in atomic units.
The mass of the
proton is about one.
The mass of the neutron is a
little bit bigger, but also
about one.
So in order to now get
the binding energy--
so the energy, which is kind
of stored in the deuteron, when
it's binding together,
the proton and the neutron
can be accessed by adding the
proton, and the neutron mass,
and subtracting the
mass of a deuteron.
Again, that's a minimal energy
needed in order to free up
the proton and the neutron.
If you add more energy,
then you actually
also give kinetic energy to
the proton and the neutron
in this reaction.
The deuteron was
discovered in 1934.
And it's fundamental
also in production
of hydrogen bonds, which were
produced about 20 years later.
So the deuteron itself is
a rather important nuclei.
Again, as I said before,
it's fundamental.
It's stability is fundamentally
important in nuclear synthesis
after the Big Bang.